- Okay.
I'm ready whenever you ready.
(lighter flick)
Okay.
- [Interviewer] Being
well dressed is a part of-
- [Louis] Man of fashion.
- [Interviewer] A man of fashion?
- [Louis] That's it.
- [Interviewer] All right Louis.
Louis where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- I'm from the Meridian,
Mississippi.
- [Interviewer] And tell me about your,
your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- Both parents
and they was together about 57 years.
I just recently lost my mother and father.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry.
- Yes, sir.
- [Interviewer] Good childhood?
- Yes.
We stayed in school.
I grew up in Mississippi
but I grew up like in poverty,
you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah
Mississippi's one of the poorest
- Yes.
states in the country.
- Yes it was.
So we would have to chase the,
excuse me for saying this.
The white man cows,
have to stayed out of school
to chase the cows in.
- [Interviewer] Say that again.
- White man cows would get out
and we would have to chase them back in.
Stay out of school to chased them back in.
- [Interviewer] Your
job is to keep the cows
from getting away.
- Yes.
He would tell us
"Stay out of school.
Don't go to school today, my cows out."
So we'll put them back in.
- [Interviewer] And if
the cows were behaving,
you guys went to school?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Understood.
- They all up,
we'd go to school.
He would come
and ask my mother to
keep us out of school.
So I grew up doing that.
- [Interviewer] What
was it like growing up?
- I had a rough life.
- [Interviewer] So you
were born in what year?
- 1963
- [Interviewer] 63.
So what was it like being a black man
in Mississippi back in the early 60s
mid-60s?
- Wow.
It was hard.
It was hard because,
they was in that segregated,
segregation stuff you know what I mean?
So we had to pretty much watch our step
and watch who we talked to.
We couldn't talk to white people,
you know it was just rough.
It was just rough.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
The racism
- But I don't have that in me.
(chuckle)
- [Interviewer] was, was, was
strong down in Mississippi
- Yes.
Yes it is.
Still.
- [Interviewer] Still is yeah.
- Still is today.
- [Interviewer] So,
at some point you got
introduced to being a pimp?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] How did that happen?
- Well I met this young lady.
She was 45
and I was only 17.
Kind of fell in love with her.
But she,
Little did I know,
she was a prostitute.
So she brought me into the game
and kind of schooled me
and groomed me
and the rest,
I kind of pretty much
learned from other pimps.
Talking to them,
going out to dinner,
this and that.
- [Interviewer] Did you have
any pimps in the family?
- Yes my uncle.
- [Interviewer] Your uncle?
- Yes.
He was a well dress man as well.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- He lived in Cleveland,
Ohio.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
Ohio is big on pimps too.
- Yes it was.
- [Interviewer] What,
what kind of stuff did he teach you
as a young man?
- He taught me to groom your woman.
Let her know what you want,
what you want 'em to do
and put them in your class.
The name of that class,
Pimping 101.
(laughs)
So in that class,
we,
I would tell them what I expect of them.
Let them know that
I was going to handle all the money.
I buy all their clothes,
I would feed them
and I would do everything.
I would house them.
So that's,
that's what the class was all about.
- [Interviewer] And what was
the arrangement financially?
How much of the money did you keep?
- I kept all of it.
- [Interviewer] All of it.
(chuckles)
- Anything they needed,
I bought.
- [Interviewer] That's a typical answer.
- Yeah,
They may come to me for this
and that
and the other
but I always break them off.
- [Interviewer] A lot of,
I think people that aren't familiar
with the world of pimps
and prostitutes are mystified at the-
- Yes they are.
Yes they are.
- And,
and explain how a female comes to you
and wants you to be her pimp
and wants to give you 100% of her money.
- Typical example,
I had one to come up
and she said
"I like your style.
I would like to be one of your girls."
I said
"You want me to pimp you?"
She was like "Yes."
So that was my second one,
you know?
So we eventually pulled 3 more in.
So I had 5 altogether.
- [Interviewer] You have five girls?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And this was in the 70s?
- This in the 70s
Yes.
- [Interviewer] Have you
ever been arrested for this?
- Yes once.
- [Interviewer] But the laws
have changed drastically.
- Yes they have.
Yes they have.
- [Interviewer] Are you,
are you still active today?
- Yeah
but I,
it's under different
circumstances now because-
- [Interviewer] But now
it's not the old days
when you were-
- Right.
Exactly.
I was into money,
houses
and cars.
But now,
you know,
stuck on them little drugs.
Thanks Happy.
You know what I mean?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Eventually I'm going to get off of that
but I still dress I,
you know,
my pride
and my dignity just won't let me-
- [Interviewer] So drugs kind of get,
got the best of you
- Yes,
yes,
- [Interviewer] recently.
what drug is that?
Is that a coke?
- That's uh cocaine.
- [Interviewer] Crack?
- Mm crack cocaine.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So back,
back to the,
what you were doing in the 70s.
How much was like robbing
John's part of the,
part of the game?
- robbin' Johns?
- [Interviewer] I mean
like it wasn't pure,
Was it purely just sex for money
- Oh yes yes
- [Interviewer] or was it sometimes sex
and then tricking guys
out of their money and-
- Right.
I would tell them to pretty much
evaluate the guys they date
because you never know who you might meet.
In that class I taught
them how to evaluate a guy
but for the most part,
you make good money.
I would set a price
and they will go,
go with the price that I set.
But,
for instance,
if I tell them $200.
Nothing no less than that.
- [Interviewer] But if a guy,
if it's clear a guy might have money?
- Right.
- [Interviewer] Then
other games are played?
and you try to get them out-
- Absolutely.
I would tell them,
"Kind of evaluate how
much money they spent,
how much they talk about their money,
what they have
and kind of peep game
and shooters."
For example,
I had one to make $2,000
off one guy.
Because she evaluated him
and then what happened?
He had a lot of money,
he had a lot of homes
and I told him,
I told her to go for the gusto.
So she did that.
- [Interviewer] Were you married
when you were doing this?
- I was married once
but it was later on you know.
I married the 45 year old.
- [Interviewer] Oh you married her?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] So she was
quite a bit older than you?
- Yes she was.
And she wanted me to get out of the game
but I just couldn't because
it was too much money,
too much good money.
I explained to her.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
So, so you were still working as a pimp
and she was out of the out of the game?
- No,
she wanted to get out,
I wouldn't let her
because she was my height of flights.
You know what I mean?
(chuckle)
She was pretty much in charge you know,
every now
and then she'd go out
and make a little money.
For the most part I didn't want her
out there making a whole lot of money.
Now things had gotten kinda dangerous.
So you know,
it's,
it's kinda rough now.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
The laws are much stricter right?
- Yes it is.
- [Interviewer] The
penalties instead of being
six months or a year or now-
- Yes.
They'll try to,
you know strike you out
if you to strike if you're 2 strike-
- [Interviewer] Yeah
- Even though you'll be going to court
fighting the case you know?
- [Interviewer] So what,
when,
when one of your girls
would get headstrong,
get a little bit,
out of line.
What would you do about it?
- Well I would,
put hands on 'em
and it's sad to say
but at that time you had to keep 'em
in line because if not,
they would take control.
You know what I mean?
So I wouldn't,
I wasn't going to have that.
- [Interviewer] And these are black women,
white women?
- I had,
one,
let's see,
3 blacks
1 was Asian and black
and I had 1 white.
- [Interviewer] And these
girls would stick up,
stick around for how long?
- They,
they stayed around for 20 years.
- [Interviewer] 20 years?
- Mm hmm.
- [Interviewer] So you're,
you were doing something right.
- Yeah.
That was good.
I loved it.
- [Interviewer] But what
are the qualities you think
a pimp needs to do this?
To be successful?
- Well,
you got to have streets,
street knowledge for sure.
Because you gotta know what zone to go in,
what zone not to go in.
You gotta be able to
stand your ground.
In other words, because if not,
you have someone out there
who just take control.
Wouldn't want you on the street.
And they'll let you down.
So you have to pretty much you know,
stand your ground.
- [Interviewer] And what
qualities do you look for in a,
in a woman?
- Sexy,
nice body,
smell good.
By the way I was buying all of that.
Name brand cologne,
perfume,
name brand clothin'
and take a shower three times a day.
You know my girls was just well groomed.
- [Interviewer] So,
so you,
your job as a pimp is to dress them,
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Give them a life that,
that makes it-
- Pretty much guiding them.
You know what I'm saying?
I would lead them through everything.
"Okay it's time for you to take a shower."
- [Interviewer] It's
almost like you were a
boyfriend,
husband,
whatever.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] To them.
- Exactly.
- [Interviewer] Did you think there's some
bit of them looking for,
you to replace the father-figure
they may have never had or-
- For the most part yes.
- [Interviewer] From that relationship?
- For the most part yes,
but I also was having sex with all of 'em.
So you know,
they was,
they was my bitches.
You know I'm sorry to say
but that's what they were.
But I would also you know,
get my issue.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] So drugs
have kind of taken hold
of your,
your life a bit now?
- Yes.
Now I,
I don't do it every day
but I do it every now and then.
I basically started
doing it on the weekends
and that weekend caught me up down here.
And I've been here ever since.
- [Interviewer] Yeah you told me that
drugs are your pimp?
- Yes, they are my pimp.
They're my pimp.
- [Interviewer] They're your pimp?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] So they,
they forced you to work.
- Yes
but I got a few girls I
put out there you know
and I don't go hard in the paint
like I used to you know.
But I would tell one to go out there
and get it,
they go get it.
- [Interviewer] And what kind,
what kind of a lifestyle would you
lead when you were at your,
at your peak?
I mean,
you had houses and cars
and stuff like that?
- Yes.
In the beginning I had,
I had $500,000 at one time
because I was pimping
real hard in Mississippi
Cause I had you know,
a lot of girls that would come
and bring me money just because
I was a good looking man.
Dressing nice,
You know what I'm saying?
I used to wear the
nicest suit,
nice Gator shoes.
And I was just smelling good.
They would just bring me money
and I also was a dancer.
I would dance with the fat girls.
You know,
that brought a lot of money,
extra 5 or 600-
- [Interviewer] The
fat girls would pay you
to dance with them?
- [Louis] Yes.
Yes.
(laughs)
Interesting.
But I would get about
$500 a night to do that.
So you know.
- [Interviewer] You're just making money.
- [Louis] Makin' money everywhere.
I was able to buy me a two stories house.
Which I lost all that.
I had about 5 or 6 cars,
you know what I'm saying.
I would buy those expensive car like BMW,
Mercedes you know,
Jaguar.
Stuff like that.
And I had a brand new truck.
I had a little low rider truck.
It was a 67.
I had a 67 Chevy truck.
I bought it out.
I did that myself.
And,
it was just,
life is just good.
I would do body work on it myself
and all that.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you have kids?
- [Louis] Yes.
- [Interviewer] And you raised them?
Altogether I have about 12 kids
but I was with 4 of them all my life.
You know what I'm saying?
I was going around making babies.
You know.
- [Interviewer] How many different women?
- [Louis] 5
- [Interviewer] 5?
- [Louis] 5.
- [Interviewer] And your,
your kids knew you were doing this?
- [Louis] No I never brought them
into that lifestyle.
I would take care of them
but they never knew,
knew what I was doing.
They thought I was working.
I would go out every night,
they thought I was going to work.
- [Interviewer] Working as what?
- [Louis] Uh.
I told them I worked at Budweiser.
(laughing)
I had a shirt that I would
wear home every night.
- [Interviewer] Have
you ever been in love?
- What's that?
- [Interviewer] Have
you ever been in love?
- Yes.
Yes.
I loved that 45 years.
She was much older than I was.
And age took a tape,
took a toll.
So I would just kind of eventually
let the pimp game go
because I would introduce crack.
And it kind of tore my mouth
out a little bit.
And,
but I've always dressed nice.
You know what I'm saying?
Kept a car.
You know what I'm saying.
- [Interviewer] Did the,
did the girls that worked for you?
Were they using drugs?
- Yes.
Yes.
I would buy the drugs.
I would buy their clothin',
I make sure they take
a nice bath you know,
shower three times a day.
That was a must.
And I would go take them to Macy's
and places like that to get
them the specific perfume.
JC Penny's.
But I had top of the line girls.
They was all nice and fine.
Coca-Cola bottles.
Figure
They was just beautiful.
- [Interviewer] What's,
what's the craziest
thing you've seen in all,
in your years of doing this?
In mostly Mississippi right?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Did you
do it in LA as well?
- Yes.
I did.
- [Interviewer] Oh you did it here.
- I brought it out here to LA.
I only did it about two years
because he got too rough out there
because I was on Western.
I had,
I had broke it down to 3 girls on Western
but I was getting into it every,
every weekend with someone.
So I just had to back
out the game before I,
you know.
- [Interviewer] So during your career,
what was the craziest thing you,
you recall?
- Crazy thing was,
maybe having sex all 5 of 'em
at one time.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] That would do it.
That would do it.
- That's may strike kind of odd
but I did that you know.
We would just have,
you know fun.
They loved it,
you know?
So I was kind crazy
and young you know.
So
- [Interviewer] And
your clientele would be?
- My clientele was mostly white mens.
A lot of money.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
Especially when I'd take 'em Hollywood.
Oh we would clean up.
That's when I was making $5,000 a night
but I just loved it.
But you have to be on your do God
because people are there
to try to take you out
because they don't want
you making all the money.
So.
I,
I fought that for a long time,
you know.
Pulling guns,
getting shot at,
you know what I'm saying?
But I hung in there.
I hung in there a good,
5 or 6 more years
and then I said
"I got to give it up."
My kids got to screaming
"Daddy you gon' get hurt."
You know.
Later on in life they
learned that I was a pimp.
You know,
so but I,
So I just sat them down
and told them what I was doing.
They seem like they was a little shocked
but,
they understood.
My daughter is a,
she went to Cal State Dominguez.
She graduated,
She got a degree in Political Science.
I encouraged her to go to Grad School.
So I paid for all of that.
Which was beautiful.
- [Interviewer] So your kids do well?
Did well?
- [Louis] Yes.
Yes.
All of 'em.
They all finished high school
and I made sure I took
care of all of them.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] All right Louis.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Not a problem.
- [Interviewer] Really
appreciate your honesty.
- I appreciate you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you man.
- Yes Sir.